alors bonsoir moi c'est quand il est ma
complice julie alors on va vous prises
on a pensé de vous souhaiter la
bienvenue à notre façon savoir staff à 1
2 1 2
quand
merci beaucoup
alors c'était la cumparsita de matos
rodriguez était une pièce écrite autos
au départ en piano solo et que on a
décidé d' arranger un piano 4 mains
parce qu'on l'aimé beaucoup
ce soit bien fait notre duo salle à
commencer par un caprice
et puis aussi un caprice est un terme au
musée qui signifie un morceau qui est
généralement libre dans sa forme mais
qui peut être à l'occasion qui peut
avoir un caractère vivre ça fait qu'on
trouvait que nous ça nous convenait bien
alors julie et moi dès l'âge de 7 ans on
a reçu des leçons de piano et puis on
s'est rencontré pour la première fois au
secondaire on aime se retrouver assez au
même piano on a découvert la musique
classique
et puis à ce moment là puis on trouvait
ça très beau à jouer ensemble ça a été
une première expérience qui a été très
révélatrice et puis on a eu la piqûre
pour la musique classique mais on ne
disait pas dans les cours d'école ça ça
a été toute une piqûre puisque beaucoup
plus tard on s'est revus et on avait
toutes les deux encore le vif intérêt
pour la musique classique
alors on s'est dit plein d'autant plus
qu'on aura on s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait énormément de répertoire écrit
pour le piano 4 mains
alors écoutez on avait du contenu du
matériel amplement et puis on s'est dit
pourquoi pas qu'on le ferait découvrir à
d'autres
alors on s'est mis à fond c'est mieux à
pratiquer bien sûr et puis c'est ça on
enlevait avoir justement à la musique
classique mais différente et paco si
c'est ça qui est intéressant alors on va
en parler aux gens qu'on de la façon que
vous appelez la maison sans parler des
compositeurs parler des époques et
découvrir soi mais au fur et à mesure
qu'on monte elle épiait ça nous
intéresse
ça fait que
c'est ça un peu qu'on appelle notre
caprices et que on a pris un peu la
musique classique prend on leur a juste
un peu adapté à comment on voyait ça
fait que pour vous donner un aperçu
on va jouer quelques extraits de pièces
de différentes époques justement ça
profite à faire les deux corées
où
et
alors c'était la mélodie en faire des
tonnes rubenstein qui était de l'époque
romantique le prochain extrait qu'on va
vous jouer c'est un auteur qui est un
petit peu moins connus qui s'appelle
césar cuit lui lui il a fait de la
musique son second métier il était au
top des puissants il était général en
pologne puis elle il aimait la musique
alors la pièce qui s'interdit qui
s'intitule l'oriental
auj
on
c'est ce qui nuit était de l'époque
classique c'est ça c'est ce qu'on disait
c'est un peu nos caprices qu'on fait
d'aller explorer différentes époques
puis différents styles aussi et puis ça
veut pas dire que parce que c'est un
caprice que c'est toujours synonyme de
facilité ou non même si c'est un caprice
en effet ça veut pas dire que c'est
facile parce que vous savez lorsque l'on
a à placer nos mains quasi chp et reposé
au même endroit et qu'il faut tourner la
page au bon moment c'est devenu donc une
pratique en soit seulement de travailler
à stan boland
alors on va vous le présenter en avoir
un extrait d'en arriver à l'aube de
queen of sheba de george frideric handel
oh
où
la peau
il
on
en
puis l'a bien moi j'étais à julie et
moment donné un peu de fantaisie e.on
pourrait bien changer de côté bien ce
petit coup elle avait raison évidemment
j'étais tout à fait d'accord mais
habituellement les pianistes duettistes
conserve le même côté au clavier mais
nous la permission qu'on s'est donné
nous a demandé on a réalisé qu'il
fallait s'adapter aux changements de
clés qu'en dites vous en parler c'est ça
donc à venir jusqu'à maintenant j'étais
assise à gauche donc c'est à dire à la
partie secundo du clavier et puis
habituellement les notes sont écrites en
clip fort à gauche et puis à droite les
notes dont est écrite en clé de sol
et puis la particularité du piano cap
man c'est qu'on a les deux mains dans la
même clé
consciente en parallèle avec le piano
solo que lui la main les notes entre les
deux faces sont réservés pour la main
gauche publie une note en clôture pour
la main droite
ça fait que si on change de côté
justement d'une pièce à l'aube alors
vous comprenez que faux faux faux
changer notre lecture d'un noble alors
deux courts extraits
on
merci à tous
c'est sûr c'était la marche militaire de
schubert et puis laval ses lacunes on
aimerait maintenant c'est les
échantillons alors carburant aux
expériences nouvelles
puis s'offrant des défis notre curiosité
capricieux nous a amenés à explorer
d'autres répertoires comme par exemple
la musique d'ambiance ni pièces en
musique d'ambiance musique populaire
on est arrivé on est un peu dans les
thèmes tv les thèmes de films les
premiers morts des films enfin c'est à
l'infini rien nous arrête quand on aime
son bien sûr et pour enfin ou delà des
apprentissages la technique et puis de
la grande variété de pièces au delà de
ça il s'est installé une chimie une
chimie et puis train qui tranquillement
depuis dix ans et qui s'est développé je
dirais par une grande présence et une
grande écoute
l'une envers l'autre et qui fait que
c'est pour ça qu'on aime tant sur sept
on est on partage la même bulle des fois
des forces éloigné un peu mort revient
dans la même veine avec on aime bien ça
c'est aussi l'exigence d'une
interprétation à musique d'ensemble
aussi qui fait que ça devient encore
plus riche et encore plus
enfin le courant passe comment audi avec
les gens c'est une expérience toujours à
gré et puis comme le disait si bien
glenn gould
c'est une citation qu'on a vue
dernièrement qu'ils ont trouvé que ça
correspondait vraiment à ce qu'on vivait
nous autres comme comme formation le
audio alors l'objectif de l'art n'est
pas le déclenchement momentanée
d'adrénaline mais la construction
progressive sur la durée
une vie entière d'un état
d'émerveillement et de sérénité
ça fait qu'on trouvait c'était vraiment
si ce nom sur ce nous allons vous
souhaiter une bonne soirée avait joué de
jo et avait ainsi également avec la vie
en rose
genre tu en une seconde
e
non
c'est beaucoup